a company in Southern California has
created an animatronic Abraham Lincoln
yes
robotic Abraham Lincoln but it has very
complex you know works in its face it's
capable of making very intricate facial
expressions and this is real footage of
the robot Lincoln robot here's a sample
of the different expressions that can
make check it out
[Music]
I saw that I thought that's pretty cool
and then I realize it turns out this
robot is perfectly suited to react to
our current US president good job boy
you have a lot of people here the press
will say it's about 200 people I
mentioned food stamps and that guy who
seriously overweight went crazy
he went crazy
[Applause]
that wall build that wall build that
wall build that wall build that wall
build that wall build that wall build
that
it turns out though that robot also
works for stuff other than the president
check it out
you got a fan
you